So the simplest predictor that uses history is
called the Branch Target Buffer. What it does is
it takes the current PC of the branch,
and uses that to index into a table, which
we call the BTB. And from this table, what we'll read out is our best guess
for what the next PC will be. But how do we know what to put in this table?
Well, we carry the PC of the branch
and the predicted PC with it through the pipeline.
So, this is what happens at fetch. Later on
in the pipeline, we have the correct PCNew. At
that point, we will compare the predicted one
with the correct one, and if they're not equal,
we will treat that as a misprediction. And, also,
we will use the branches own PC to index
again into the BTB, and write this new PC,
that is correct, into the table so that next
time we see this branch. We get the correct
prediction assuming that it's jumping to the same location. But
there is a problem with our BTB, how big does it needs to be. We want it to
in once cycle, given the current PC predict the
PC, so it needs to have a single cycle latency.
That means we want it to be really
small. However, it needs to contain an entire instruction
address. Let's say we're using 64 bit addressing,
that means each entry is 8 bytes. And we
need one entry for each possible PC from
which we can fetch. The program can be large.
Note that an instruction can be four bytes,
yet we need eight bytes in the BTB. So
really the BTB needs to be as large as the program
itself, which is really large. So we cannot have a dedicated entry
in the BTB for every possible PC address. We need the
BTB to be much smaller than that. How do we do that?